i love cheesecake a lot of people love
cheesecake i love cookies and cream a
lot of people love cookies and cream so
i had this idea of making a cookies and
cream cheesecake that was just purely
black and white but had the cleanest
layers possible during my time at tasty
i've gone through a lot of phases there
was you know the giant food phase and at
one point reoccurring phase was the
layer phase i
absolutely love layers i think they're
beautiful i think that can be really
cool very visual the thought process was
that i would take you know the base
would be the cookies the filling would
be the cheesecake that also uses the
fillings from the cookies and the top
would be a thin layer of like those like
pulverized like ground or fine powdered
of the cookies so you get like a black
white black look so pretty much is you
start with the base you make the filling
and then do the top so the base is just
crushed pulverized cookies that you mix
with some butter
[Music]
you bake it like a graham cracker crust
it's pretty simple you just put it in
and bake it you kind of really want to
press it flat so there's no huge lumps
[Music]
so that goes in and after you separate
the filling from the cookies you want to
save the cookie filling to make sure
that you can use that for your
cheesecake filling you mix that with
some cream cheese and it's a pretty
standard cheesecake batter recipe what
makes this a no-bake recipe is that it
uses gelatin to help set the mixture so
gelatin mixture is then whisked back in
to the cheesecake mixture so it creates
this really smooth really nice really
velvety kind of texture that also has
the melted cookie filling in it so you
don't really waste anything here it's
kind of you know you separate the cookie
into the crust you separate the filling
into the cheesecake it's basically
you're redefining the shape of what the
cookie looked like in the first place
once that filling is set you want to
pour that into the
baked cheesecake mold and that kind of
sets in the fridge you want to make sure
that it's as smooth as possible no lumps
if you really need to and you see lumps
and flecks of stuff
you can sieve it you can patch it
through a mesh sieve to get rid of any
impurities if you really want to that
goes in the fridge for a very long time
if you actually want the cleanest layers
possible you can throw it in the freezer
it's not going to make a difference the
taste and the texture because by the
time you serve it it's going to be cold
anyways and the reason why i didn't bake
this one is because when you bake a
cheesecake
i'm maybe i'm not good at it but i found
it pretty difficult to get like this
perfect smooth like top layer with no
bumps no dips no crevices or anything so
i went for the no bake route so this
recipe is pretty simple and the key i
think to really getting those clean
layers is after the whole thing is done
you do want to put it back into the
fridge or the freezer if you put it in
the freezer you will get the sharpest
cleanest layers possible this is one of
my personal secrets for cutting cakes
cutting cheesecakes cutting pies is
either freezing them or semi-freezing
them because the knife goes through it
goes straight down it doesn't bend it
doesn't really drag on anything it
really helps give you those nice clean
layers so it's a play on a cheesecake
that i think was very fun it satisfied
my layer cravings at the time
although i definitely made a lot more
layered stuff after that but it is a fun
recipe it doesn't require too much
cooking too much baking it is a no-bake
cheesecake so you don't actually have to
use your oven which i think is pretty
cool because i don't have an oven at
home and it's just an all-around recipe
that pretty much everybody is going to
like so if you do make it for a party
it's a crowd pleaser i guarantee people
are going to enjoy it you do make it let
me know i think it's a great recipe
it it can serve about 8 to 10 people or
if you're really hungry one to two it is
a great recipe if you do make it let me
know if you have questions if you have
questions also let me know i'll be here
making my layered stuff so happy baking
or no baking in this case
[Music]
you